a vegan diet has been shown to
upregulate genes that protect against
cancer anytime you see a nutritional
epidemiological study anything that says
oh this is linked to that you know meat
is linked to cancer or this is
associated with that if the the
likeliness the likelihood that that will
be an accurate statement is 0 to 20% of
the time vegan diets and lifestyle
interventions have been shown to grow
telomeres the caps at the ends of our
chromosomes that correlate with our
longevity it's not the fat you eat that
becomes the fat in your blood but the
carbohydrates you eat and vegetarian
diets are almost always higher in
carbohydrates more animal protein more
premature death more plant protein less
premature death that is just a critical
flaw when you're saying let's assume a
vegan vegetarian diet which we've only
had access to that the last 20 to 30 40
years is something that we can rely upon
for the whole human race when it doesn't
supply the basic nutrients needed for
human life
tonight's resolution again reads there
is little or no rigorous evidence that
vision vegetarian diets are healthier
than diets that include meat eggs and
cheese arguing for the affirmative
nina tae shoals nina nina please come to
the stage our greens for the negative
dr. David Katz David please come to the
stage
but Jane please close the voting right
Nina you are rocketing through the
affirmative so you're up please come to
the mic Thanks great
well I I feel like I missed out I didn't
go to McDonald's before the debate
because I could just stand up here and
say tremendous and I'd win that would be
it
so well you know I'm very excited to be
here I think there's a special free song
of excitement actually in the room
tonight because I don't know if many of
you know it but there's actually it's
sort of a history between David Katz and
I that's from the past few years and and
this is the first time that we've met so
that's exciting and I'm going to just
tell you a little bit about that I mean
I'm I'm here because I wrote this book
and when it came out in 2014 it was much
acclaimed I had spent nearly a decade of
my life diving into the science and read
thousands and thousands of scientific
studies and I got it was best book of
the year by a number of really important
outlets and lauded by medical journals
and yet there was this Yale doctor who
was writing these terrible things about
me like he was saying I was only out to
sell a book and that was the only reason
I had written what I had written my book
my book is based the central argument is
that saturated fats have been unfairly
vilified and do not actually cause heart
disease and so so he said that I was
only out to write a to sell books like
yeah good plan spent a decade of your
life store to write a nonfiction book
but it got worse that I was a parasite
of science and that I was a fool or a
fanatic that I was Apparel or that I
lived in a was a wingnut living in the
basement of my mom I just want to know
when I lived with my mom I was allowed
to live on the top floor and and then it
finally came to being quoted in The
Guardian as saying I was like an animal
unlike anything he'd ever seen before
which really really hurt my feelings and
a number of doctors wrote in to the Dean
of Yale Medical School to say well
what is going on here this is not very
professional behavior and got the reply
that that dr. Katz is not associated he
doesn't teach her he's not a professor
at the Medical School and he runs a
research program at a local county
hospital that got the name of Yale some
years ago and so that made me feel
better but I also just want to explain
I've been asked like by so many people
why I would be here tonight it is hard
to be on stage with somebody who's been
so uncivil to you and I'm and I guess my
answer is is that I really believe in
the science and I really think it's
important I think these kinds of attacks
are are just not about science it's so
important that we understand and debate
the real science I care so much about it
so that is why I'm here and thank you
so what are we debating we are debating
a hypothesis that vegan and vegetarian
diet diets are superior in health to
diets with with animal foods in them in
order for a hypothesis to be considered
as somewhat true or we can we can start
to believe in it it's truth it must be
supported by rigorous evidence that's
human clinical trials and those trials
must be replicated and it must not be
contradicted by a large body or really
very many facts to the contrary which
undermine it there's a wonderful quote
by the biologist Thomas Huxley who said
the a the great tragedy of science is
the slaying of a beautiful hypothesis by
an ugly fact so we are going to see if
there are any of those ugly facts out
there tonight why is this debate so very
very important the true Health
Initiative is dr. Katz's foundation and
he says that you know we really
everybody really should eat a
plant-based plant predominant diet and
he says that everybody agrees on this
this is their point that everybody's in
sync with this and I think dr. Katz and
I agree that the that we are really
struggling with the chronic diseases
that afflict our country but there
really is disagreement about what is the
best diet to prevent those so I have to
explain to you this really big word now
nutri epidemiology and even longer
nutritional epidemiology
because in order for us to really talk
about the science and nutrition we need
to understand what is the science and
nutrition so I'm going to take you on
this little journey nutritional
epidemiology is when you take a large
group of people like this who all looks
so happy right now and you ask them a
bunch of questions what do you eat you
exercise do you take pills what do you
you know do you have a nice family life
do you go to church and then you follow
them over time and you see who succumbs
to disease or eventually death what
kinds of conditions do they get and so
you have many many income variable
variables all the things they eat and
everything they do in their life and
many many outcome variables everything
that possible that could happen to human
health and as really there's all these
correlations like a thicket of
correlations and what happens is you get
false positives inevitably there are
things that are going to correlate with
each other that do not are not causation
I mean here we have one of these
correlations internet use causes breast
cancer I don't think so
maybe sitting in front of the computer
all day it causes cancer who knows but
this is a false positive here's another
one a false positive whereby if you
decrease the amount of margarine that
you eat apparently you can save your
marriage
that seems cheaper than a marriage
counselor but that is unlikely to be a
causal link
epidemiology only choses shows
associations associations and
nutritional epidemiology is particularly
fraught because it depends on people
reporting on what they ate so just
imagine this so every six months you get
a questionnaire how many apples did you
eat on average over the last you know at
six months every week how many pears how
many how much lasagna and can you
quantify that by cup and and and can you
let's hope that that's the your lasagna
is the same recipe as my lasagna in my
database back here and how many people
do you think out here just raise your
hand if you might be likely to lie about
how much sugar or alcohol that you
imbibe right would so there's you know
the science really shows that people not
only don't remember what they eat but
they lie about
they don't mean to it's just they don't
want to be seen as looking bad even in
an anonymous questionnaire they don't
want to think badly about themselves so
this data is very unreliable I'm just
gonna slide over this one but that the
unreliability of that data is profound
and that is really at the heart of the
problem with using nutrition
epidemiology there is a better kind of
science called a clinical trial you know
ideally a randomized controlled clinical
trial and that's where I take a group of
people like you and over here at this
group I give you a pill or I give you a
diet and this group over here I is my
control group I give them a placebo or I
give them a control diet and if you're a
big enough group and I consume I can
assume that everything else about you is
equal except for the intervention the
pillar of the diet and at the end of art
period let's say a year I can decide
let's say you risk group all drops dead
from heart attacks I know that it's due
to my unfortunate intervention and that
is the kind of science that can show
cause and effect so when nutritional
epidemiological findings are tested in
this more rigorous kind of science
nutrition clinically I have been shown
to be correct and in this one study by a
Stanford professor only 20% of the time
in this study they were pre correct zero
percent of the time so anytime you see a
nutritional epidemiological study
anything that says oh this is linked to
that you know meat is linked to cancer
or this is associated with that it's the
the likeliness the likelihood that that
will be an accurate statement is zero to
twenty percent of the time this latter
study that showed that zero percent
actually looked at all the findings of
the most influential epidemiological
database in the country at Harvard
looked at all their findings they were
the ones who tell us to take various
supplements and also to do hormone
replacement therapy to remember that all
based on epidemiological findings
altogether 52 of these epidemiological
findings were studied and they found
that zero percent of those could be
confirmed in clinical trials and this is
not an idle thing you remember hormone
replacement therapy millions
women are taking hormone replacement
therapy only to find when they did the
clinical trial that they had a higher
risk of having a heart attack so this is
not an idle matter that is that that is
why we cannot trust this kind of science
and why if you look anywhere in the
world at systems for grading and
understanding science they will put they
will put in that middle layer that kind
of aqua blue is where all the
epidemiology is and on top of that in
the darker blue is randomized control
clinical trials that's where you start
regardless of the system you're using
whether it's the system [ __ ] crane from
the UK or one called grade from from
Canada it's controlled clinical trials
that are the gold standard so just as
you would not prescribe a pill to a
patient based on an epidemiological
study this is linked with that but we're
not sure zero to twenty percent odds
that were right you would not do that
with a diet so what is the rigorous
clinical trial evidence for a vegetarian
or a vegan diet let's look at this the
US dietary guideline committee in 2015
looked at all of the available trial
evidence they could find at the time and
and from an analysis that we did we
found that 11 of 14 members in that
expert committee actually themselves
were had published in favor of
plant-based diets so we knew that they
were if there were more any trials to be
found they would find them they had an
incentive to find them they couldn't
find any and they had to rank that
evidence at the lowest possible grade
that is available for when you have any
evidence so that's the government's
systematic review here's another
systematic review of clinical trials and
heart disease they could only find that
only 836 people had been tested which is
not very many and they found that
although those trials lowered your LDL
which is your bad cholesterol supposedly
it also lowered your good cholesterol
your HDL that came down in in a vegan
vegetarian diet that's a sign of your
heart disease risk increasing and those
diets also almost always increase your
triglycerides which are the fatty acids
in your blood why because it's not the
fat you eat that becomes the fat in your
blood
but the carbohydrates you eat and
vegetarian diets are almost always
higher in carbon
hydrates anybody knows this I was a
vegetarian for over 20 years I avoided
meat red meat butter cheese everything
like the plague and when you're not
having meat for dinner or you can't have
an egg pie you're having pasta
grain-based meals you're having cereals
you're you're used to bake my own bread
you have a high carbohydrate diet and
that drives up your triglycerides and
that is another sign of your worsening
cardiac risk so at all this is a mixed
outcome a mixed grade for vegan
vegetarian diets and heart disease
what about diabetes this is the latest
consensus statement that came out of the
American Diabetes Association which has
always been hostile to low carb diets
but it's come out saying for the first
time we believe that low carbohydrate
restriction is really the best is the
best course that you can take and it it
said that there was not ample evidence
particularly for a vegan or vegetarian
diet and that those diet showed a fairly
small ability to reduce your average
blood glucose measures which is called
hba1c I just want to go to this this is
one of the meta-analysis they cited this
is the bigger of the two that they cited
there were only two that were available
and you can see here this is David
Jenkins who's a vegan vegetarian who is
said has on the record is saying he
thinks everybody should be vegan
vegetarian this person is somebody who
works with an animal activist group so I
just want to show you that there's this
is one of the reasons that we're all so
confused there's a lot of bias in the
literature but even they could find oops
even they could find very little
evidence of any kind of benefit from a
vegan vegetarian diet for reducing
diabetes again that blood glucose
decrease is only 0.29% by contrast sorry
I have to go through this all again a
recent low carbohydrate trial after one
year found a six point three to seven
point six percent reduction that is just
I mean compare that to 0.29% reduction
and and you know low carbohydrate diets
are not always high in animal foods but
they are definitely it are definitely
much more common
contain animal foods so that really sort
of blows away really any other diet
what about non alcohol aholic fatty
liver disease a rising epidemic we're
not sure exactly what causes it may be
too much fructose but you can see that
the diets from this review paper the
diets they single out are either
Mediterranean or paleo as being viable
ways to combat that disease but not
again a vegan or vegetarian diet so what
are the arguments that dr. Katz uses
when he's defending his his point of
view he often talks about the blue zones
the blue zones I don't know if you know
them that came from this book it was the
author went around the world and found
what he thought were the longest living
people and he who wrote them up in his
book I actually have this book at home
and I looked at it for the first time
just last week when I was preparing for
the debate and it was stunning to me
that there's no footnotes in it so you
really can't check anything so it is
surprising to cite this as your primary
resource it's because you can't look
anything up but one of the blue zones is
one that we all know really well which
is the Okinawans who are reportedly
supposed to live very long and do live
there is a cohort that has been very
very long-lived but I mean just to give
you an example of why it's so hard to
trust this kind of evidence because they
did a dietary sample of these people in
1949 when the island was had they just
Japan it just lost world war two the
island was occupied by US soldiers they
were not they were barely feeding their
prisoners and they and and over 80% does
it say over 80% had symptoms of being
malnourished so when you go into a
population you have no idea what these
people ate when they were young or as
teenagers or for the rest of their lives
I mean you have no idea what made them
long-lived you can't say it was their
diet in 1949 that was an exceptional
sample here's another this is another
sort of study that dr. Katz likes the
site of the Tasmanian people in Bolivia
he also plant-based diet I just wanted
to look at that study a little more
closely
today had very low calcium scores it's a
sign of heart disease and if you but if
you look at their diet it turns out
there's no pay there's no information on
diet in the paper it could they refer to
another paper where the diet was taken
on only breastfeeding woman and that
paper says that 83% of the women are
having meat every day how am I getting
it right fish every day and 63 percent
said having meat every day and even that
paper sort of then cites another paper
which you know so you're three degrees
removed now from getting the real
dietary data so a very tenuous kind of
data I just want to give you one example
I mean it's like you know you can
cherry-pick certain into these dimples
but there are so many counter examples
this is a study on 1 million men in
India where the southern Indians eating
mostly plant fats had were heart disease
rates 7 times higher than the northern
Indians eating 8 to 19 times more fat
mostly dairy fat and the southern
Indians died 12 years earlier so I can't
go through all my examples now because
I'm running out of time
but here's just a couple of other facts
that contradict this idea that eating
more plants will protect against disease
we eat 44 percent more plants foods
today than we did in 1970 I took sugar
out of there because I didn't think that
was fair but it's still is not saying
they caused these diseases but they have
done a terrible job of combating them
let's just say that and here's animal
foods you can see whoops animal foods
I'm sorry
all gone down while obesity and diabetes
have increased so it's very hard to make
argument that these have caused those
diseases what else do you have to ignore
in order to believe that vegan
vegetarians are are the best for health
all of human civilization right I mean
ever since you are young we I mean ever
since the humans that have been young we
have eaten meat and dairy and it's in
all of our art it's everywhere a british
captain navy surgeon captain is as
quoted as this one my favorite quote
saying it's just ludicrous to believe
that a modern diseases could be could be
blamed on an old-fashioned food
this is just a timeline of history I
mean you'll see this is where at the
very end here we start to get access to
fruits and vegetables year round it's
only possible because we had we fly them
in by plane and train and automobile
I mean people sitting in this room right
now in May we would be like struggling
there'd be no more moldy apples in the
barrel there'd be no more root
vegetables we'd be waiting for June to
get our next fresh fruit or vegetable so
it has only been possible in the last
you know a few decades that we've been
able to eat fresh fruits and vegetables
year-round so all of these facts
contradict the idea that vegan
vegetarian diets could be superior for
health and now just a quick word about
saturated fats which are not only in
meat but in food dr. Katz likes to say
that saturated fats he believes they
still cause heart disease these are some
of the most tested fats in the world
huge clinical trials on 25 thousand
people and most of them in patient
therefore highly controlled and the
results are having no effect of
saturated fats on cardiovascular or
total mortality just none so this
hypothesis has been tested more than any
hypothesis in the history of nutrition
and disease and the results have been
null this is a chart you're just gonna
have to take a graph a picture of and I
can explain to you later but it shows
that for all the hard outcomes death and
cardiovascular mortality all the review
papers find no effect of saturated fats
okay I've got a minute left so I'm gonna
skip all these slides and just say this
is the state of evidence on the vegan
vegetarian diet it remains a hypothesis
it has not been rigorously tested in in
randomized controlled clinical trials
human evolutionary history does not
support it and there was a great deal of
contradictory evidence so it is now
incumbent I think upon dr. Katz to show
that there is indeed rigorous clinical
trial evidence that supports the idea
that vegan or vegetarian diets are
superior to health then
diets with animal foods thank you very
much thank you Nina dr. David Katz
arguing for the negative take away James
gene Brett thank you thanks very much
gene okay good evening folks
so this exactly this and only this is
what we all agreed to see debated here
this evening this is the resolution
there is little or no rigorous evidence
that vegetarian vegan diets are
healthier than diets that include meat
eggs and dairy the first person that I
invited to join me here this evening
after my wife who's here as well as two
of my Brooklynite daughters was Mark
Bittman this was because mark and I did
a couple pieces together recently in New
York Magazine on diet and health trying
to make sense of the science and we're
writing a book together now and it's
nearly done and I thought it would be
helpful for mark to sit in and listen to
this exchange but mark wrote back to me
right away and the enviable bastard said
I can't come I'll be in Bermuda I don't
know that these guys are in Bermuda but
they're wearing Bermuda shorts anyway
after telling me I can't come I'll be in
Bermuda he went on to say you do realize
that resolution is a sand trap and I
wrote back and said yeah so how much is
little and who decides what exactly is
rigorous and who gets to tell whom what
is the operational definition of
healthier actually these hours are
slightly out of place so what exactly
are the vegan vegetarian diets we're
talking about what is healthier and most
importantly in that arrow so we have a
formatting issue here but that's
supposed to land on include what does
include me is that eight times a day or
once every eight months so yes it's a
sand trap but I knew that coming into it
but the the resolution specifically and
I didn't choose it I had no input into
the wording here I just accepted the
invitation
the resolution is a negative
it asserts an absence of evidence and so
while I am trying to demonstrate the
existence of evidence my counterpart has
to demonstrate an absence of evidence
there is little or no rigorous evidence
and proving a negative is an impossible
standard even if I fail to show you any
rigorous evidence there might be some
somewhere we haven't proved that there
is none and that's the job so John
Oliver said impossible to prove a
negative so yes this is my situation
tonight I readily concede that however I
think my counterpart situation looks
more like this the job is to prove a
complete absence of evidence so we'll
see how that plays out I hope these
arrows do land in the right place up
here so the the issue then we need to
discipline is what do we mean by
vegetarian gene I think you're in the
way if you know thanks what do we mean
by vegetarian vegan diets and what do we
mean by diets that include meat eggs and
dairy and I think we have to discipline
the resolution just a little bit because
this Plus this is vegan and throw this
in and it's vegetarian and I didn't come
here to debate this nonsense and I trust
you didn't come here to hear this
debated it only makes sense to have this
debate if we're talking about sensible
balanced whole complete reasonable
vegetarian and vegan diets and frankly I
don't think the debate made so much
sense either if by diets that include
meat eggs or dairy we need an optimal
plant-based diet that rarely includes a
bit of venison or an optimal plant-based
diet that rarely includes a bit of wild
salmon or an optimal plant-based diet
that occasionally includes Greek yogurt
right I think what we need to compare
here is diets that are built out of
plants and diets that routinely include
meat eggs and dairy and by the way the
resolution doesn't say or it says and so
I think that's the relevant comparison
that's what I came here to talk about
now even accepting the invitation under
those circumstances I'd like to point
out that this is not an argument I think
makes any sense at all because there are
good and bad vegan and vegetarian diets
and frankly I don't necessarily think if
we just focus on human health at an
optimal
vegan diet is demonstrably better than
an optimal Mediterranean diet so
basically I've been asked to come here
and fight left-handed and like inigo
montoya I am NOT left-handed but I
accepted the terms of the exchange so I
will fight left-handed so the resolution
again is that there's little or no
rigorous evidence that vegetarian vegan
diets are healthier than diets that
include meat eggs or dairy so again
these arrows are falling in odd places
so let's agree I'm not sure where that
one's supposed to go but I think it's
vegetarian vegan diets let's agree we
mean sensible complete vegetarian vegan
diets healthier let's agree we mean less
premature death less chronic disease and
improvement in well validated biomarkers
that are predictive of those and let's
agree that we mean include is routine
it's not very rare inclusion of Greek
yogurt it's routine inclusion of meat
eggs and dairy that makes the debate
interesting and then we can shift our
focus to the core of it because this is
actually not a debate folks about
dietary details those haven't really
been specified it's a debate about
evidence the core of this debate is
little rigorous and no so if we accept
the resolution as what's being debated
here this evening know is wrong if I can
show you any little is wrong if I can
show you a bunch and rigorous well who
gets to decide well there are objective
standards for rigorous evidence some
were already mentioned here this evening
grade is a scoring system for systematic
reviews most of the scientific community
signs off on the fact that meta analyses
systematic reviews and randomized
control trials are at the pinnacle of
evidence BMJ pretty much agrees with
this they have their own spin on it the
Center for evidence-based medicine at
Oxford University pretty much agrees but
since I am obligated to stand up here
this evening and defend to you this
notion of rigorous evidence I thought we
should voir dear me I'm essentially the
expert witness right am i qualified to
say I think evidence is rigorous so I
have been asked to do review articles on
diet nutrition for the peer-reviewed
literature
I've authored multiple editions of a
leading nutrition textbook for
healthcare professionals used in medical
education I've co-authored multiple
editions of a leading epidemiology
textbook v is in production right now
this has been translated into a bunch of
languages I'm not sure what all these
languages are to be honest with you
written a textbook on evidence-based
medicine I'm going to talk to you this
evening about randomized control trials
I have conducted and published these
multiple times I have control trials I'm
going to talk to you about systematic
reviews I have conducted and published
these I'm going to talk to you about
meta analyses I have conducted and
published these and I have invented
research methods we'll talk about
research methods I've actually invented
methods of evidence synthesis most
notably evidence mapping this goes back
to 2003 this is a widely used measure to
assess the quality of evidence in
diverse medical fields we actually have
a new invention related to evidence
synthesis called helm hierarchies of
evidence applied to lifestyle medicine
this paper is currently under review at
medical research methodology so I have
to show you some evidence to refute none
I have to show you a bunch to refute
little and I humbly submit that I'm well
qualified to adjudicate rigorous but
particularly if I cleave to objective
standards like for example randomized
control trials so let's just talk about
randomized control trials of vegetarian
vegan diets and as I do this and I pull
up these text boxes so significant
reductions in lipids and inflammatory
markers with the portfolio diet that's a
vegan diet every one of these randomized
control trials I'm about to show you
compares a vegan or vegetarian diet to
an omnivorous diet and in every case
what's in the blue box is verbatim from
the paper so I'm not editorializing here
so basically a vegan portfolio diet
lowers lip is as effectively as a statin
and the omnivorous counterpart diet did
not work as well this study shows that a
vegetarian diet was more effective than
a non-vegetarian Mediterranean diet at
lowering LDL cholesterol
this and again all randomized control
trials of various sizes cardiovascular
risk reduction was optimized by a heart
high carbohydrate meaning a high plant
food by the way carbohydrate is plant
food all plant foods or carbohydrate
sources so there was a better effect on
lowering cardiac risk markers with a
plant-based low glycemic diet than a
meat-based low glycemic diet and against
a little hard to see from this angle so
forgive the turning TMAO is
trimethylamine n-oxide it's a potent
atherogenic metabolite this randomized
trial of multiple diets showed that the
only way to reduce TMAO was to take meat
out of the diets and when meat was
replaced with plants TMA plummeted this
randomized trial shows that a low-fat
vegan diet improved glycemia and plasma
lipids more than conventional diets
recommended for diabetes by the American
Diabetes Association this randomized
trial showed improvement in insulin
sensitivity beta cells are where insulin
is produced through a low-fat
plant-based diet compared to an
omnivorous diet this randomized control
trial showed that reducing saturated fat
intake is associated with reducing
intrahepatic fat fat in the liver leads
to insulin resistance this was really
interesting it was an over feeding study
saturated fat produced more fat in the
liver than over feeding the same number
of calories from sugar or anything else
this randomized control trial compared
it was a feeding study basically a
hamburger versus a vegan meal of
comparable calories there was impairment
in got hormone responses and increased
oxidative stress after the hamburger but
not the vegan counterpart this
randomized control trial shows vegan
vegetarian diets all better for reducing
the dietary inflammatory index of potent
mark of chronic disease risk this cart
this randomized trial shows in patients
with coronary disease a vegan diet
lowers high sensitivity c-reactive
protein a potent inflammatory marker
this diet shows that dye quality scores
increased significantly on a vegan diet
but not counterparts that's important
because these diet quality scores the
HEI alternate healthy eating I realize
this is a lot I'm sorry these in turn
correlate with all cause mortality
cardiovascular disease cancer type 2
diabetes this randomized trial shows
greater weight loss in the vegan group
compared to the omnivorous group this
randomized trial shows more again weight
loss compared to an end SEP that's the
National cholesterol education program
this randomized trial shows plant
protein produces particular improvements
in body composition during weight loss
this study showed that plant-based
protein is good at controlling hunger
and satiety as animal protein during a
weight loss experience another
randomized trial reduction intramuscular
fat with the vegan but not the
omnivorous diet another randomized trial
mean BMI reduction greater with whole
food plant-based these researchers go on
to say they think this is the greatest
weight loss seen at six and twelve
months when you aren't specifically
restricting calories another randomized
trial perhaps the most famous Dean
Ornish randomized trial patients with
coronary disease this was a randomized
trial de novo people realize this but
here a plant-based diet caused actual
regression of coronary atherosclerosis
that's shown on top the bottom images
are PET scans they show cardiac
metabolic function the orange is normal
leftist before right is after the
lifestyle intervention with a
plant-based diet these images show the
effects of the same plant based diet
area intervention this is from the
Cleveland Clinic and the orange study
went out five years and at five years
the folks who had this plant based diet
intervention they had further regression
of their coronary plaque the control
group had twice as many cardiac events
that's mi sudden cardiac death
admissions to the hospital for heart
failure and we don't need to decide that
this is rigorous evidence the Centers
for Medicare and Medicaid Services have
already done that for us they've
concluded that this program meets the
intensive cardiac rehab program
requirements set forth by Congress and
Medicare reimburses for this program of
plant-based nutrition as cardiac rehab
and as an alternative to coronary bypass
surgery this interesting randomized
trial shows improvement in mental health
with a vegan diet as compared to
omnivorous controlled right depression
anxiety etc this was a multi-site
intervention at work sites this is just
a sampling of randomized control trial
there are many more it's already too
much to show you I apologize for the
pace of this but it's the nature of the
enterprise now let's look at systematic
reviews and meta-analyses I'll go
through these very quickly so these are
exclusively meta-analyses systematic
reviews most of them are meta analyses
of randomized control trials some of
them are meta analyses of cohort studies
and some a combination of the two so
there is some variation in the mixture
I'm just trying to carefully watch the
time so this shows an association in
meta analysis between vegetarian diets
and lower blood pressure than with
omnivorous nights omnivorous diets of
course diets containing meat eggs and
dairy are the control in every instance
this meta analysis shows vegetarian is
associated with lower levels of high
sensitivity c-reactive protein this meta
analysis shows reductions in multiple
markers of inflammation including
c-reactive protein fibrinogen leukocyte
concentrations this meta analysis shows
lower mean concentrations of serum
cholesterol on vegetarian vegan diets
another meta-analysis substituting meat
with high quality plant protein
associated with favorable changes in
blood lipids and lipoproteins again
these are mostly meta analyses of
randomized control trials another one
vegan diet is associated with more
favorable cardio metabolic profile
another meta-analysis the portfolio diet
reduces the 10-year risk of coronary
heart disease this is a vegan diet
another meta-analysis vegetarians have
significantly lower scheme at heart
disease and mortality another
meta-analysis lower risk of colorectal
cancer in the vegetarian and vegan diets
another meta-analysis inverse
association with vegan diets and
diabetes risk another meta-analysis
diets that produced the highest scores
the these various measures of diet
quality have the lowest levels of all
cause premature death cardiovascular
disease etc and the highest score on
these measures is a high quality vegan
diet and another meta-analysis
significant protective effect verses the
incidence and mortality from ischemic
heart disease and cancer okay just a
sampling all right it is just a sampling
all right now I want to argue so I'm a
scientist I've done this my whole life I
want
argue that although these are the
objective standards of high quality
evidence I don't know that they
necessarily are the most robust evidence
but let me first ask you a question how
many of you would agree that in order to
know something is true not believe it's
true or wish it's true or hope it's to
know it's true you need evidence that
it's true to know something's true it's
a little hard to see right to know
something's true you need evidence is
true and how many of you would agree
that to know something is true with a
very near certain level of confidence
you need rigorous evidence that it's
true you're being cautious right you
know something with near certainty can
you note when you're certainty without
evidence okay how many of you know if I
toss this Apple up be honest it's gonna
fall back down and not float away
so I guess the evidence was very strong
was it a randomized control trial was it
a meta-analysis see I think science is
being abused and misused I think the
most robust evidence is remarkably
consistent patterns at massive scale on
obvious display and so frankly we can
know a lot from observation yes we need
randomized control trials to populate
gaps and later in the evening if there's
time I'll tell you the specific role of
RCTs they are not the be-all end-all
they don't answer every question so you
knew what was going to happen in this
Apple it's just the consistency of the
pattern so yes I will talk about the
blue zones because there are five
identified blue zones where people live
to be a hundred and don't get chronic
disease and they're very diverse but if
we were to plot their diets on a scale
from animal food predominant to plant
food predominant they would cluster at
the plant food predominant in they range
from mostly plants to all plants and yes
that's important and then there's a lot
of other evidence so gene expression a
vegan diet has been shown to upregulate
genes that protect against cancer this
is a whole body of literature all in its
own vegan diets and lifestyle
interventions have been shown to grow
telomeres the caps at the ends of our
chromosomes that correlate with our
longevity the higher the intake of
dietary fat from animal
sources to hire the all cause mortality
the higher the fat in our diet from
plant sources to lower the all cause
mortality exactly the same with protein
more animal protein more premature death
more plant protein less premature death
and frankly the observational evidence
just goes on and on and I'm not going to
characterize all these right enough
enough because my only job is to show
you that there isn't no evidence and
there isn't little evidence and a lot of
this evidence is rigorous so on and on
and on and on and on
Lancet study 195 countries more
premature death all around the world
with more intake of highly processed
food which is also bad not all plant
food is good obviously but more meat and
processed meat lower rates of premature
death around the world with more intake
of vegetables fruits and whole grains
copy that the common denominator in all
of the literature on lifestyle
interventions is plant-based nutrition
and while you may think I'm showing you
lots of studies tonight actually I can't
I can only show you a small sampling
because there's just too much literature
on this topic it just goes on and on and
on and on and on and on and on so there
is little or no rigorous evidence that
vegetarian vegan diets are healthier
than diets that include meat eggs and
dairy well or no is clearly wrong
because there's some little is wrong
because there is a [ __ ] whack and for
those of you who are quantitatively
punctilious a [ __ ] whack is 1.2 American
shitloads and it is objectively rigorous
evidence including but not limited to
multiple RCTs meta-analysis systematic
reviews thank you
[Applause]
so now we're gonna get the two rebuttals
you'll be ready for your questions and I
just wanted clear in terms of way I do
things is yes I wrote the resolution but
both sides are given the opportunity to
read and improve the resolution and
indeed both sides did and I'm now
bringing Nina for the for her rebuttal
and okay well there's obviously too many
studies to even respond to here but
let's let's start with the Apple okay so
every study that dr. Katz showed you
after the Apple was an association study
that means it's an epidemiological study
that means the odds that those studies
would be correct are 0 to 20% I just
want you to remember that it is it is 0
plus 0 plus 0 plus 0 is still 0 no
matter how many of them there are when
he was going through before the Apple
the systematic reviews and the meta
analyses I counted 11 of them he showed
us 10 of those were on observational
epidemiological studies again zero plus
zero plus zero plus zero a lot you can
show a lot of slides a lot of data but
if it's not reliable is the tragic the
tragic problem of data not being able to
prove cause and effect and we've seen
we've seen it through hormone
replacement therapy we've seen it
through our being told that we should
not eat cholesterol and avoiding eggs
and avoiding you know egg yolks and
shellfish and then that being wrong
those are the tragedies that happen when
you rely on lesser evidence you cannot
add it up and have it be anything more
than what it is which is unreliable
zeros I like the point about the Apple I
think it's clever aid is true we should
trust our senses on certain things and
what do we see when we look around us in
America today we see out of control
epidemics of obesity and diabetes and
heart disease and cancer and fatty liver
disease that is what we can see with our
own eyes without anybody
telling us and we have since 1970 been
eating more and more and more plants
food and fewer and fewer and fewer
animal foods so that is something that
just is some an observation we can all
see we have tried really hard to follow
these plant-based more green guidelines
and that has not worked out for us I
want to just there's a number of
clinical trials that dr. Katz did show
before he went on to the systematic
reviews and meta-analyses and I think
that one thing that's really important
to say is that the reason that you look
at meta-analyses and systematic reviews
is that they are able to sift through
all of those clinical trials and make
judgments about them many of those
clinical trials that he cited you know
some of them aren't randomized some of
them are you know a cholesterol-lowering
diet is not necessarily a diet that's a
vegan diet or you have problems there
are all kinds of criteria that go into
deciding whether a clinical trial is a
good trial and and should be included or
as not does not meet your adherence
standards that is why I only presented
reviews by credible bodies and I only
presented systematic reviews of
randomized controlled clinical trials
and so even as I said when the dietary
guideline committee went around to
looking for it's it's it randomized
controlled trials for the vegetarian
vegan diet they couldn't find any okay
one final note on the Ornish trial which
is the one that supposedly showed the
progression of heart disease that was
one trial on 41 men who were put on some
of them were put on his vegetarian diet
it was a multifactorial intervention so
anything it was included cessation of
smoking and more exercise in yoga and
meditation and supplements so you don't
know if there were good outcomes if as
he said if if that was due to the diet
or any of these other interventions on
his trial the good cholesterol HDL
declined as it always does in a
vegetarian diet was a sign of increasing
cardiovascular risk on his trial two
people died in the
intervention group versus one in the
control group which is something he
doesn't often advertise but that is a
well in certain parts of the nutrition
world oh you call that a 100% increase
in mortality so another you know I can't
go through all the trials that he showed
were by Neal Barnard who is an animal
rights activist who starts with the
point of view that we should not be
eating animals at all and that is his
starting point scientifically and his
study that he when he showed TMAO which
is something he said he could only fix
by eating less meat actually it's much
much higher in vegetable so reducing
vegetables is better for reducing TMAO I
just want to say it's just a very highly
selective group of trials there and you
really have to rely on review papers
that have done a good job of weeding
through good and bad trials and when you
do that you find there's little or no
rigorous evidence for the vegan
vegetarian diet
[Applause]
so to be clear bread I'll count on you
to get get us started here to be clear
you know nobody advocates for eating
junk and actually there's been no
increase over time an intake of fruits
and vegetables in the United States so
you know if we're talking about
multicolored marshmallows as part of a
complete breakfast yeah that's gone up
but there's more than one way to eat
badly and again bread if we got the
slides you got him here okay so what
we're debating and by the way all the
trials I showed you were randomized
control trials and you know I don't know
if anyone here gets to decide okay was a
randomized control trial but I didn't
like the author so it doesn't qualify as
rigorous evidence I don't think it works
that way so they were all randomized
control trials and most of the meta
analyses were of randomized control
trials and as I mentioned some included
observational studies so this is the
resolution again but are there studies
that can show that eating meat is better
and how is that even possible
what if vegetarian vegan diets or plant
predominant diets are unquestionably
better how can how can it ever look
otherwise well there are three reasons
comparison conflagration and context
comparison is key this study by Lee at
all looked at a hundred thousand people
over 30 years and then carved out the
ones who reduced their intake of
saturated fat from meat and dairy and
asked the question that is routinely
neglected what did they eat instead well
if they substituted refined carbs and
added sugar it was a sideways move
they're the same rates of heart disease
there is more than one way to eat badly
and the American public is committed to
exploring them all that's sort of the
takeaway message here to say seriously
okay however if they replaced saturated
fat from animal sources with unsaturated
fat from plant sources rates of heart
disease plummeted if they replace these
calories with whole-grain calories rates
of heart disease plummeted right so the
instead of what question comparison is
key the other issue is conflagration
it's so easy to create a straw man and
then set fire to it so a lot of these
studies that suggest eating meat is good
well I told you I don't think we want to
talk about the cocoa
cotton-candy vegan diet but some people
do and so a lot of the studies you hear
about this was a randomized control
trial we randomly assigned people to an
omnivorous diet in a vegan diet
you think bias doesn't figure into that
and by the way the fact that you can
hear these randomized control trials
were biased well that's that's a
precaution that's universal right ah so
they can be biased so maybe we need
other forms of evidence too because if
this is the vegan assignment it's a
straw man and if this is the vegetarian
diet it's a straw man and then context
is key sometimes eating meat is a really
good thing this poor child has
kwashiorkor it's protein deficiency this
doesn't happen in the US but it still
happens in the Sudan and other places
around the world what is good to eat is
totally dependent on epidemiologic
context we eat too much meat eating more
vegetables and fruits and whole grains
beans lentils nuts and seeds would be
better because of the nature of our
diets and the nature of our epidemiology
but no amount of evidence regarding the
existence of B evidence say for meat can
prove the non-existence of a and again
my job here was to argue there is a [ __ ]
lack of rigorous evidence supporting
vegetarian vegan diets as in fact there
is now there's debate about what
constitutes high-quality evidence we
could spend time going into the weeds
here but I'll simply tell you for now
our CTS have both strengths and
weaknesses
there is no single definitive source of
high-quality evidence but no we're not
clueless about the basic care and
feeding of Homo sapiens if we were if
our science were really as useless as
some content we'd have no basis to know
whether jelly beans or pinto beans were
better for us science is a set of tools
they can be used well or badly and
frankly we spend a lot of time using
tools badly I do RCTs they have
limitations we have no RCTs to prove the
harms of smoking and it was the
merchants of doubt from the tobacco
industry who made hay with that for
years you don't always need RCTs and you
can ask bad questions like which step in
a long hike is the active ingredient we
don't do that in exercise research we do
just that kind of silly thing in some
nutrition research I don't know why but
it does get done so frankly we have an
aggregation
of diverse sources of evidence they all
point in the same general direction
plant predominant to plant exclusive
diets produce more years in life more
life in years there isn't no evidence
there isn't little evidence there's a
lot of evidence and much of it is
rigorous by absolutely any standard
thank you David and we now go to the Q&A
portion of the of the evening so please
line up with your questions at any time
if either of you want to ask each other
question you can do so I want to start
promoting the moderators prerogative and
ask you each a question question for you
new titles is there any sort of evidence
that you say is rigorous is there any
controlled rigorous trial randomized
trial evidence that you could cite on
behalf of your contention having to do
with meat any evidence that you could
cite that that that meat diets are are
healthier than plant-based diets yeah I
mean there's quite a bit of clinical
trial information on I mean anytime you
compare a diet that has some animal
foods in it to a vegan or vegetarian
diet and that has there's only a handful
of those studies where they do compare
them depending on it really depends on
that outcomes but there's there is and
especially if you are if it's meat and
animal foods and it's high-quality and
they're reducing carbohydrates they
always perform better in terms of their
cardiovascular outcomes their
weight-loss outcomes their ability to
control glucose control that's why you
see the American Diabetes Association
selecting that though that dietary
pattern so the clinical trials on meat
specifically are there's two systematic
reviews of clinical trials on meat that
I know of that show that cardiovascular
outcomes are improved
one of them looked at 0.5 ounces or
servings of meat per day and showed
increased benefits cardiovascular
benefits for eating the meat versus not
eating the meat and there is one other
review on cardiovascular outcomes that
also showed that meat was beneficial
looked better for cardiovascular
outcomes thank you David you want to
comment on the question under the answer
well at least peripherally so you know
again I think we established at the
beginning and both said very similar
things about what constitutes rigorous
evidence
I get the sense that's been turned into
a slippery slope it's rigorous unless I
don't like the study you know I think we
ought to honor the standards that in
play what I'd like to refer back to Jean
if I may is the fact that I'm fighting
left-handed here this evening and I am
NOT left-handed so my fate many of my
favorite long-term randomized trials are
about reducing meat intake so you know
again vegetarian vegan diet studies is a
very small slice how do you improve the
health of a population that eats too
much highly processed food and gets an
excess of saturated fat by the way
that's a simple-minded notion that
saturated fat is bad you know what's bad
imbalance is bad if you had no saturated
fat in your diet added some it would be
fine if you already have too much and
add more it's bad we're just prone to an
excess one of my favorite studies this
is a multi-country randomized control
trial is the Leone diet Heart Study this
was a randomized trial throughout
countries of Europe where people who had
already had a myocardial infarction were
randomly assigned to their customary
diet so in northern European diet which
by the way is much better than the
typical glow-in-the-dark junk lead here
in the United States so it wasn't
optimal but yeah it wasn't all
frankenfood either and the intervention
diet was a Mediterranean diet that
systematically shifted them from animal
foods to plant foods and shifted their
fat intake from the saturated fat that's
concentrated in meat and dairy to more
unsaturated fat notably the oleic acid
that predominates in olive oil but also
fat from nuts and seeds avocado fish and
seafood in lieu of beef and terrestrial
animals and there was a 70% reduction in
the rate of recurrent MI over the
multi-year span of the study really
quite stunning now I couldn't cite that
this evening because I was box
into vegetarian and vegan but the bigger
argument here is what would improve your
health what would improve the health of
the American public is it eating more
meat eggs and cheese or is it eating
more fruits and vegetables and the
evidence there is overwhelming and
frankly incontrovertible that it's
eating more fruits vegetables whole
grains beans lentils nuts and seeds but
you do you do advocate the plant-based
diet though
well I advocate a diet that's mostly
you're asking my you know that wasn't
that wasn't the resolution well I think
well into the prevention but I
personally advocate diets for human
mostly plants yeah yeah diets that are
mostly comprised of minimally processed
whole fruits vegetables whole grains
beans lentils nuts and seeds plain water
one thirsty yeah you penny you wanted to
comment Nino asked that David a question
yeah oh yeah I just want to respond to
just a couple of things that are
inaccurate the lion for so the Leone
diet heart trial it was it was not a
multi-country study it was only in Lyon
and it was specifically to look at a
kind of margarine they had made up Thai
was was linoleic acid and they and it
was a study where they did very little
it was very poor in terms that there was
actually very little difference between
the two groups in terms of the dietary
intake and it was it was not a study
looking at a plant predominant versus a
more animal predominant was mainly to
look at this effect of this margarine
that they were interested in because
they were interested in the so-called
Mediterranean diet with olive oil but I
want to also increased it just correct
two other things you said when you said
we haven't increased fruits and
vegetables in this country since 1970
we've increased our consumption of
fruits by 35% and our consumption of
vegetables by between 20 and 25 percent
and that I went to look into that
because I was curious like you what are
they talking about do they mean ketchup
you know neither of us I think are
talking about or in good faith about a
junk food vegan diet and actually the
greatest increase in vegetables that we
eat a four hundred and thirty three
percent increase is in leafy greens that
Americans are eating more of which are
supposed to be the kinds of vegetables
that we're supposed to eat and there was
nothing so we do eat more fruits and
vegetables and just a final thing I want
to correct is this idea that saturated
fat is synonymous with meat the
foods that are the highest concentration
in saturated fats are plant foods that's
coconut oil and palm oil we use we have
a lot of us we all eat palm oil in all
of our packaged foods that's where we we
get they're all made with palm oil
because the stable fat so it's it's
incorrect to say that saturated fat is
synonymous with red meat and or in dairy
it's just in act well let's set aside
the saturated fats cuz yeah I wanted to
actually needed to the question I I
wanted to put to you David reject which
is has come up which is only this isn't
there evidence that that there has been
noticeable improvement in him in in the
American diet per capita consumption of
meat is down per capita consumption of
sugar is down but capita consumption of
fruit and vegetables is up so are you
saying there's been no improvement or do
you not do knowledge that there has been
data showing a tangible statistical
improvement and if so wouldn't you want
to look for tangible improvements in
health as a result of that improvement
that's my question okay but but first
everything we just heard about the Leone
diet Heart Study is inaccurate and
you're gonna have to pull the papers
yourself from the peer-reviewed
literature to check that out please
refer to the period and then we'll
follow up and then let's address the
question so there has actually using the
objective measures of diet quality over
very recent years and and thank goodness
and frankly people I think it's because
we've run out of new and innovative ways
to eat badly there has been a slight
improvement in diet quality I think part
of what is fueling that is at long last
an interest in this notion of Whole
Foods and the idea that the less
processed the better and and so there
objectively measured there's been a very
slight improvement in diet quality this
was reported by the same unreliable
folks at Harvard that are responsible
for a lot of the research we heard is
useless but I guess we trust them when
we like their outcomes so there's been a
slight a slight improvement in measures
of dye quality I've looked at data from
n Haynes which is the national health
nutrition examination survey conducted
by the CDC I cannot find evidence there
that we have increased fruits and
vegetables as a proportion of calories
if we qualify refined grains as a source
of vegetable intake
obviously that's gone up if we think of
fried potatoes as a vegetable and by the
way ketchup and marinara sauce on a
slice of pizza qualifies as vegetables
under the US federal guidelines so
theoretically and we're told we're
increasing our intake of vegetables a
lot of its that that the other important
thing is that the entire food supply is
booby-trapped
to be addictive Michael Moss a Pulitzer
Prize winner has written about that and
so our total intake of food has gone up
and total calories have gone up and by
the way our total intake of fat never
went down
it's just that fat as a percent of
calories went down a little bit because
our total calorie intake went up and
this is pretty well documented again by
Ann Haynes and others so no no no per
capita I thought it happened a reduction
in consumption of red meat and per
capita consumption of sugar yeah well
sugar has been going up sadly until
quite recently it's threatened a little
bit red meat has gone down and we have
shifted from plant-based from from
animal-based fats to plant-based fats so
two quick comments about that and then
I'll wrap up so you know frankly yes
there has been a slight improvement in
diet quality and there has been a slight
decline in the rates of major chronic
disease in particular cardiovascular
disease associated with this trend to
eat a bit less meat and eat a bit more
animal products plant products however
this issue of saturated fat from
multiple sources is true historically we
got our saturated fat from meat and
dairy as people cut back on meat and
dairy sadly they don't start eating more
lentils and broccoli they start eating
highly processed food made with palm oil
which is a highly saturated tropical oil
may be better than animal fats for human
health but that's very contentious
probably not and frankly quite
devastating for the rainforests in
Borneo which are being cut down to make
palm oil plantations and ultimately
that's bad for us too so yes sources of
saturated fat have shifted over time but
historically the preponderance
of saturated fat in the diets especially
of Americans has been from meat and
dairy yes their saturated fat and
coconut but come on folks how much
coconut do you actually eat right I mean
so it's just not a major source it is a
source it caught on as a popular cooking
oil for a while and then the blush is
off that rose but most of the saturated
fat in the American diet has
historically been and frankly remains
meat and dairy okay questions from the
audience uh please I don't see you out
there but if no you have to be online at
the mic go down there okay please state
your question has a question
don't tell us who you are just ask your
question my questions for dr. Katz how
does your diet deal with the presence of
anti-nutrients implants like oxalates
phytates etc excellent question so again
this is not my diet
I'm not sell selling any diet here I you
know I'm here talking about plant
predominant and plant exclusive diets
because that's the resolution we agreed
to so you know that they're there a lots
been made particularly by this guy
Gundry who wrote the plant paradox and
there are anti metabolites in plants and
in particular he talks about lectins but
we could pick anything else out right so
you mentioned several others you realize
that oxygen is one of the more potent
human toxins known you know that if you
breathe pure oxygen you'll be dead in
about 72 hours it's a real problem when
we're taking care of patients in the
intensive care unit I'll spare you the
gory details but titrating oxygen can be
a real challenge so therefore there is
an anti respiratory breath see who cares
okay so pure oxygen is toxic there's
oxygen in the air actually some of its
good for us and we need to breathe so
really the question is what happens to
people eat the foods I think one of the
great tragedies in all of this discourse
on the topic of nutrition and human
health is the fixation on isolated parts
as opposed to the whole people don't eat
nutrients they eat foods what happens to
people who eat a diet rich in
vegetables fruits beans lentils beans
and lentils legumes in particular
concentrated sources of these lectins
that Gundry tells us to fear in
intervention trials and at the level of
whole populations observed over
generations and if I may just for a
second quickly you are not going to have
ever a randomized control trial that
tells you what happens to somebody over
their entire lifespan
you cannot randomly assign newborns to a
diet and expect them to adhere for 280
years if we don't derive some of what we
need to know from observational
epidemiology most of what is most
important will never be known what
happens over entire lifespan does this
add years to life does it add life to
years but both intervention trials in
the short term randomized control trials
meta-analyses population studies
observational epidemiology and
ethnography of entire populations over
the span of generations which no RCT can
ever do show that these foods with
remarkable consistency pretty much that
much consistency are associated with
more years in life more life in years so
who gives a damn if they're anti
metabolites in the food please my
question is also for dr. Katz when
observing the different trials
specifically comparing the omnivore
diets to the vegetarian vegan diets I
can't help but wonder when looking at
the the meat products and the dairy
products that the omnivores were eating
was the quality control as far as the
processing goes
ergo another way to ask the question is
for the vegetarians and vegans eating
very high quality plant products and
meanwhile the omnivores we're eating
McDonald's burgers and other very highly
processed foods that are just generally
unhealthy thank you for a beautiful
question insightful honest and and what
I can tell you is sadly and and you know
this is this is why no we cannot rely on
any one study and no single RCT will
ever give us definitive truth and in
science what we rely on is the weight of
evidence from multiple sources and this
kind of careful looking under the hood
is required so I pointed out to you
from the perspective that I'm arguing
this evening the danger of a straw man
right so if I want to show that eating
meat is better than a vegan diet all I
need to do is to dine it design a study
of a truly awful vegan diet so coca-cola
and cotton candy is the vegan diet and
frankly anything's better than that
exactly the same in the opposite
direction so if you are a vegan
ideologue you can design an RCT that
compares that to a really bad never
study I tried when I curated RCTs that I
showed you here this evening to select
studies of high quality and even if the
researchers were biased to look at the
details of the methods to make sure the
methods weren't biased that they didn't
set this up so in many cases the
comparison diets I showed you were the
National cholesterol education program
recommendation so it's a high quality
omnivorous diet the American Diabetes
recommendation high quality omnivorous
diet and and a high quality
Mediterranean omnivorous diet compared
to a vegetarian version so I think it's
a it's a really good question and a
universal precaution RCTs as valuable as
they are and again I've made my career
for the last 20 years running them they
are subject to the bias of the
investigator and they only ever ask
answer the question you asked and if you
want to show that an omnivorous diet is
bad can you design into your study a bad
omnivorous diet as the comparison
absolutely so you really have to look
very carefully at that and and again I
think what it means is look at a
diversity of methods look carefully at
the details of studies and only base
your conclusions on the overall weight
of evidence which is what I've tried to
do throughout my career any coming from
you Nina no no and yeah I mean I just
think that you know when you flash
through that number of clinical trials
without anybody being able to read them
or under see them there's no way we can
be assured and you're arguing one side
of a debate we have no assurance that
that you were actually are curating
those clinical trials in a way that
would be at all fair the one clinical
trial that you went into any depth on
which was the Ornish trial we saw quite
clearly if upon inspection was was not a
it wasn't did not show what you had said
it showed so I think that it's very hard
to I would I would assume is the
audience that's not necessarily
trustworthy that some like you know a
very a rapid-fire list of clinical
trials that you've curated was a fair
curation question yeah this is also for
dr. Katz you had actually mentioned the
in Haynes data that you had looked at a
little bit earlier I was fortunate to
actually get a hold of it and I was
especially interested in how those
people above 50 seemed to have a higher
rate of death per year if they had lower
LDL relative to those who had higher LDL
and in fact this even includes the
centenarians of the in Haynes data set
which I found to be quite interesting
much of the data that you were
presenting from earlier have a lot to do
with the presumed positive effect size
of a vegan diet in how it lowers LDL did
you have a comment for that sure thank
you so to be clear you know and frankly
I can't argue about the rapid-fire
presentation of clinical trials the
resolution is about the existence of
evidence I had to show that there's a
bounty of evidence and I wish there had
been more time to go into detail and
routinely I do that but that's not what
tonight allows for a reduction in LDL
with these plant-based diets was just
one of many effects all of them lined up
in a direction that's favorable and by
the way it's now widely accepted in the
cardiovascular community that if you
lower LDL which is what all of the
prescription drugs approved by the FDA
for the treatment of dis lipedema and
coronary disease do that what happens to
HDL isn't important if you get LDL low
enough HDL ceases to be a meaningful
predictor at all but my answer to your
question is reverse causality we
actually published a paper many years
ago about the unreliability of
cholesterol levels when we admitted
patients to the hospital because it
always plummets so if people have
chronic disease if you look at mortality
and lower LDL the question is was there
the presence of a chronic disease
accounting for the incipient mortality
risk and their LDL was falling because
of the presence of chronic disease
there's a really it's a it's an arduous
thing to do in epidemiologic studies to
control for that window
where you're subject to reverse
causality because actually people's LDL
is falling because they're sick so it's
not that the low LDL is causally
increasing their risk of dying it's that
their increased risk of dying because
bad stuff is happening inside their body
and it causes their lipid levels to fall
that's pretty well known yeah I mean
just say that LDL lowering through drugs
is is very different than has LDL
lowering through diet has never been
consistently shown to be related to
cardiovascular outcomes what you do with
a drug and what happens with drugs has
not been confirmed in diets so the LDL
question your doctors putting you on a
diet to lower your LDL and he's putting
on a drug to lower your LDL the diet
lowering LDL through diet is not well
correlated with your cardiovascular
outcomes each gel is in fact much better
correlated with your positive
cardiovascular outcomes in diet I'm we
have time for one real question
take it away please go ahead yeah hi
David Katz that was a great presentation
I've been a big fan of yours and it's
someone's riddle well would you please
ask the question you pointed out many
common interests many conflicts of
interest amongst the vegan authors and
the biases associated with that but I've
noticed that you're not a physician like
yourself like David Katz who spent a
lifetime trying to you talk about being
the science so do you mind just
explaining your financial conflicts of
interest like where the money from their
books are sold go to and your speaking
engagements and things like that yeah I
mean conflicts of interest is a super
important topic I am I do not receive
any money from industry like David Katz
I give speeches and I could speak just
to all kinds of groups and I just give
the same speech to everyone if if if
tomorrow at the diet the US government
were decide to to endorse a diet higher
in in meat and dairy I wouldn't make a
single penny I don't I don't profit from
from any industry and I'm not I I don't
have to share
any company I will say it is very
distinct from David Katz who who is not
only as a CEO and and founder of a
plant-based diet company and has a long
list of companies in which he is paid
for scientific advisers he received more
than $750,000 from her she's received
more than 2050 thousand dollars from
Quaker Oats he's given testimony to
defend Chobani the high sugar content of
Chobani yogurt at his standard rate of
thirty five hundred dollars an hour I
mean I think there is a huge number of
companies in which he is involved and
invested and I will say that I'm not
involved in any company or get money
from any industry David you want to
respond no yes up to you I don't think
that's true
I actually read a refutation of that in
Politico that kind of followed the money
trail related to the beef industry in
the dairy industry so I think most of
what we just heard is untrue
to correct that it does not say it says
I sat in a room and there was somebody
in the room from the cattlemen and that
is not anything that I work for them put
that in your summary okay you finish
your remark David thank you yeah so
actually I've not received money from
these food companies we've done funded
studies and actually all its testimony
to I first of all if you are
constitutionally opposed to industry
funded research you would go into a
pharmacy there'd be nothing on the
shelves you do realize that almost all
drug research is industry funded so the
issue is the quality of the research the
nature of the contract so my lab over
the years has had funding from a number
of food companies including a number
from the egg nutrition center and as you
can hear I'm arguing tonight against
routine consumption of eggs but we
published a series of studies that found
no harm of X including in folks with
coronary artery disease the results of
the results you don't get to choose so
we did an intervention study we used
endothelial function as the primary
outcome so in in every case where we've
had funding in our lab whether it's NIH
CDC u.s.
industry foundations we've had a
hypothesis we've tested it in his
unbiased a manner as possible we produce
the results and you know as for the rest
I I'm not CEO of a company that has
anything specific to do with plant-based
nutrition I do engage in a number of
professional activities that are related
to things I believe are important and
you know and I think we have to be
careful at about hitting one another
over the head with this idea of conflict
of interest what it makes me think of is
there was a time when a group of
Republican senators called out Al Gore
for having investments in the green
economy and gore said yeah and and the
idea was he was advocating for these
companies because he had investments and
he said no I was advocating for these
companies and then I invested in them
because I thought were supposed to put
our money and our effort and our time
and our passion where our convictions
are okay not the same all right thanks
time for the summaries Nina us summation
yeah I just want to keep up size 1991
you know I definitely agree that it's
great to put your your money in things
that you believe in but when you do that
to a great extent you are you know and
these are some of your conflicts of
interest here that when you do that it
really becomes it's very hard than to be
a credible source for being objective I
mean it's it's almost impossible to say
well my my opinion comes from my
financial benefit or that I might that I
might reap our or that it comes from my
genuine evaluation of the literature
which is why although I have been
offered numerous jobs as scientific
advisors and and shares and companies
that I know will do very well I've
rejected them all because I don't want
to ever have that kind of conflict of
interest you know I think that this is a
kind of a nice segue into a you you're
an event you're the founder or have been
deeply involved in this supplements
company and I think that's a kind of an
eye
and I just want to say that you know
other things in which you denied are all
on your CV so anybody which is on your
website so anybody who wants to go and
look at these numbers about how much
money you've received from various
places can look on your CV that's where
I got them so I just like to do my
summation I think this point about
vitamins and supplements is a really
important one well first let me just
talk about the clinical whether there
has been little or no rigorous evidence
that has been presented I would still
argue that despite there was incredibly
long summary of clinical trials at the
beginning because we were able to
scrutinize none of them and because
other bodies scrutinizing this body
these clinical trial data have not found
them to rise to the level of being able
to endorse them to prevent diabetes to
prevent heart disease to to be included
in the Dietary Guidelines despite a bias
for plant-based diets those bodies did
not deem those trials to be rigorous
enough this idea that we can then rely
on epidemiological evidence because the
clinical trials do not tell us
everything that we want to know is still
just I think a failed concept you know
it's this idea that it is hard - yes it
is hard to do - to design an airplane
but if that's hard but but if you fail
in that it doesn't mean that magic
carpets fly you know it just means that
clinical trials are hard to do they are
hard to do but they've been done in the
past and they can be done again and they
are the only way that you can show cause
and effect and again you cannot is the
tragic the tragedies of the past where
we have seen that we have relied upon
epidemiological evidence and gone
forward with policies that turn out to
be wrong again many women lost a hormone
replacement therapy people who gave up
and eating egg yolks and and missed out
on needed nutrients and I think the last
thing that I just want to say do you
have my summation sides my conclusion
sides oh okay so I just want to say so
again just going back to this pyramid of
evidence we have not seen randomized
control trials in a way that we can
speculate that we can understand them
and actually evaluate them and
understand that they're viable we've
only seen observational
from you and again this idea that a
vegetarian or vegan diet could even be
viable to sustain human life these are
some of the nutrients that you need to
get in order to survive and maybe one of
the reasons you're you know a investor
or an owner of a supplement company is
that you on a vegan or vegetarian diet
you must take supplements you must
especially take b12 which does not exist
in plant foods and many many nutrients
and supplements minerals and vitamins
that are essential for life are either
not available in plant foods or they're
in there less bioavailable form
I think iron is a really good example of
that you cannot get from spinach what
you get from meat and that's true in
many ways lack of vitamin b12 is
extremely dangerous and leads to birth
defects so I think that that is just a
critical flaw when you're saying let's
assume a vegan vegetarian diet which
we've only had access to that the last
20 to 30 40 years is something that we
can rely upon for the whole human race
when it doesn't supply the basic
nutrients needed for human life that is
a very difficult argument to believe and
then again there are these anti
nutrients in plant I think a question
you kind of brushed off but they're very
real they decrease the absorption of
iron protein iodine iron zinc magnesium
and and and all kinds of so it makes it
less possible there are many people who
cannot eat these plant foods also you
cannot get the long-chain omega-3 fatty
acids from plant foods flaxseed oil
won't do it so you cannot get those
essential nutrients that you need for
life from plant foods so I will just say
you know you've spoken a lot about your
your authority in the field and all the
trials that you've done and you know one
thing I would say is it's true you've
done a lot of this research but it does
it's like a sports that there are people
who can write about sports and they know
a lot more about the sports and the
baseball players themselves are out on
the field doing it but you know it's a
fallacy to appeal to Authority it
doesn't matter who is right it matters
what is right
you're the conclusion while I'm Thank
You Brett so while waiting for the
slides to be up here actually folks
first of all you can know something is
true without an RCT but what I presented
to you was a lot of RCTs
but I want to point out something else
that was omitted tonight actually
avoidance of hormone therapy because of
two RCTs the Women's Health Initiative
and the Hearst trial has resulted in an
estimated 90,000 premature deaths in
women in this country because the data
were misrepresented it was a very small
increased risk in some women not in
others and we've actually scared women
who would benefit even in terms of
survival away and the correction comes
from observational epidemiology we need
multiple sources of evidence and by the
way you didn't hear me talk about
nutrient supplements here this evening
all right so not really relevant to the
resolution this really is my view in in
common with Michael Pollan diets are
better when they're real food mostly
plants when I reviewed this topic for
annual review of public health this was
the conclusion that I reached we were
specifically told tonight to talk just
about human health effects what is the
real argument for say vegan diets is it
human health effects no I don't know
that an optimal vegan diet is better for
human health than an optimal
Mediterranean diet I think they're
pretty comparable frankly they're both
massively better than the typical
American diet which is the seafood diet
i seafood and I eat it but if we look at
the trifecta of more years in life more
life in years human health ethics and
environmental impact which we were told
not to talk about this evening that
actually makes an extremely powerful
case for plant predominant to even plant
exclusive diets and frankly this is
really important because we are
destroying biodiversity on our planet we
are changing the climate and all of this
we were asked not to talk about so I'm
not talking about it
except to tell you that for a physician
not to talk about it is incredibly
irresponsible because there are no
healthy people on a ravaged planet and
so frankly the impact of our diets at
scale on planetary health if you don't
think of that as part of your health you
are misguided and that was the basic
conclusion recently of the Lancet
Commission report and by the way the
Dietary Guidelines Advisory Committee in
2015 explicitly recommended limiting me
to intake and eating more plants and
included a vegetarian recommendation
based on their review of the literature
it was the politicians under lobbying
from the beef and dairy industry that
expunged that from the official dietary
guidelines but this and only this really
is what we were asked to debate here
this evening a debate is either about a
resolution or it's not so if we can
change the topic mid debate I'm not sure
what I signed up for but I accepted an
invitation to debate this issue there is
little or no rigorous evidence and I
think actually both parties agree that
multiple randomized control trials
constitute rigorous evidence meta
analyses of those trials constitute
rigorous evidence
so yes you haven't had a chance to read
all those papers so there's a bit of a
he-said she-said but how was that going
to be otherwise unless you became
content experts here this evening I
presented just a smattering of the
relevant evidence but I think it's more
than enough to show that no evidence is
demonstrably wrong there's obviously a
lot of evidence now you could debate
whether every one of those trials is
completely reliable or not but little
evidence is also wrong or is it all good
evidence do you like those studies do
you like the authors well you folks can
take your time and figure that out but
there's a [ __ ] lack of evidence that's a
simple fact and since the evidence I
presented was preferentially randomized
control trials meta-analyses and
systematic reviews which everyone agrees
are at the pinnacle of types of evidence
even though frankly I think other forms
of evidence are extremely reliable the
resolution is wrong thank you
I'm Xavier with that that concludes and
the the evening's debate and Jane you're
opening the voting for the closing vote
meanwhile I hope you enjoy this evening
and that you can come next month in June
the that is next month very different
resolution rather dry sounding defended
by Professor Teresa girl du chí of the
new school will defend the resolution
the Social Security system can't add to
the federal deficit cannot add to the
federal deficit and taking the negative
will be me
and so I will be debating professor
Teresa grilled uchi and guest moderator
will be Nick Gillespie so you don't want
to miss that and that would be June 17th
now events for which we suggest you buy
tix right away because we're selling it
out will be August 12th the Cato
Institute's George Celgene will defend
the resolution
bitcoin is poorly suited to the purpose
of becoming any nation's main medium of
exchange opposing him will be Safa tea
and a moose author of the Bitcoin
standard the decentralized alternative
to central banking on Tuesday September
10th part of the problem podcast host
Dave Smith the very guy who does our
warm-up acts each month will be a
debater defending the resolution the
libertarian party should never again put
up national candidates whose views are
similar to those of Gary Johnson and
bill weld against Nicholas saw walk
chair of the libertarian National
Committee Dave a newly a dad is gonna
double dip that evening he's gonna be
earning a fee as our debater he will
also be doing the warm-up act and that
evening so that's going to be a double
dip from day
and Knicks our walk has agreed to that
deal so there's no problem from Nick
people the Green advance dr. Katz when
they come to the wording and everything
else which you did you agreed never to
speak up what what didn't you speak up
yeah you you agree never to speak of the
in Vienna
there's other things that you agreed
never to speak about because they're not
run anyway and also the the University
Tuesday November 5th
another event actually which is gonna
involve me once again emeritus professor
Richard Wolffe will be defending the
resolution socialism is preferable to
capitalism as an economic system that
promotes freedom equality and prosperity
he will be defending that resolution
again in that case opposing him will be
me and this time I promise not to lose
my temper those those who viewed my
debate with Bhaskar of occasionally Sun
Kerala and socialism occasionally
admonished me don't lose your temper
again in fact it turns out that I've
been told that that debate I did was
Bhaskar as a reason podcast has had more
viewings than any other reason podcast
in history I guess a lot of people
wanted to see me lose my temper it
turned out but but but it's not gonna
happen again
not when I debate a professor Richard
Wolffe I want to guarantee you of that
now as a bonus other good stuff coming
up the sella forum will take to the seas
from July 5th to 12 Jane I think you're
looking at me and I think you have the
final vote you can close the voting what
the kanto be a contra cruise hosted by
Tom woods and Bob Murphy I'll be
moderating a sole forum debate on the
Contra cruise to Alaska
starting July 5th 2 through 12 a
pacifist Society is morally and
practically superior to 1 using
defensive violence it's going to be a
defense of pacifism with a Bob Murphy
taking the affirmative against Tom woods
I'll be moderating that resolution I'll
be doing some other presentations on
board like this trip to Alaska
accompanied by my wife I hope you can
all come I got you all a promo
if you go into contra cous if you put
just put in Soho you can get $100 off
the contra cruise and I'll be on board
so this could be fun alright now we we
have the final vote and let's see thank
you voting voting YES on the resolution
initially 52% voted YES on the
resolution that went up to 57% so that
was a 5 percentage point increase so
that 5% is the number to beat
voting no on the resolution was 16% that
went up to 29% picked up 13 percentage
points so the turkey roll goes to dr.
Katz
[Music]